hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and
vishwanatham Anand the Magus Coulson is
the Challenger and the witch monitor and
the defending champion now you've seen
my series under 2013 candidates
tournament if you haven't I will put a
link to it in the description below you
are more than welcome to check it out if
you haven't before checking out this
match because if you don't then you will
not know that it could have easily been
avoiding a chronic playing this match
against the chuan at an island if
eventually did not defeat kramnik in the
final round of the 2013 candidates but
it was quite an eventful tournament and
you know it could have gone either way
but in the end here he is the Norwegian
Magnus Carlsen
twenty-two-year-old challenging the
world champion for the title the game
was the entire tournament well the match
was played in China in the capital of
Tamilnadu it's also Allen's hometown so
Anand does have the home advantage but
that will prove to be of little use as
this is a chess game and and we do have
a couple of photos before we check out
the game here is Carson shaking Allen's
hand and here we have I think this is
the photo before actually round one
began and you can see all of the
photographer photographers in the news
reporters and you know just casual
kibitzers are watching behind a glass
wall this was implemented in this
tournament and in a couple of matches
before that so the players are not
distracted by by the viewers but after
this event there will the glass wall
will no longer be used here we have
another photo of this you can see people
enjoying the show behind the glass wall
so okay that being said Carson Carson is
the Challenger here but it's a rare
occasion that a challenger is almost 100
rating points higher rated than the
world champion which is the case here so
some people thought that Coulson would
easily win this match because he is the
straight player in history of chess and
he's twice twice on the 8th twice as a
young is he he's twice his younger son I
don't know if that's the correct way to
say it
Anand is twice his age that's maybe a
better way to do it but Anand has a much
more experience in world chess
championship matches and cousin has no
experience in World Championship matches
so you know there was a difference in
opinions how would this magical but it's
also very interesting for me because I
would also very much enjoy going around
you know round by round and really you
know increase my own vast knowledge of
this match as well and hopefully you
will do so this is round one let's check
it out Coulson has the white pieces and
he opens with nice to f3
we have d5 just a second there
sorry about that
[Music]
we have d5 Dorothy opening is on the
board g3 g6 Bishop to g2 and Bishop to
g7 the Kings Indian attack double finish
at oh variation d4 we have c6 castles by
Carlsen Knight to f6 be three castles
Bishop to b2 and Bishop to f5 c4 by
Carlsen Knight B to d7 and here the
first surprise of the game so it was a
very well known opposition at the time
this game was played crossing plays
Knight to c3 in previous games tonight B
to d2 was played as the denied from d2
we'll keep keep an eye on the c4 pawn
and defend it more as night the b6 is
coming and this will pressure the c-4
home but this was crossing preparation
and it's interesting because one of the
people in Carson's training camp was
Lauren fresney who who also played
Knight B to d2 in 2012 against maxime
beaugeois graviton ice game after 94
knife to h4 and Ike captures captures
and then after Bishop to e6 avoiding
Knight captures Bishop C capture C
captures rook a to c1
Queen to b6 Knight to f3 rook you have
to see it and gossip to f3
white did have a nice game so probably
this is all Constance preparation and
present a had something to do with this
as he thought Knight to c3 it can
definitely be played so okay Anand
immediately tries to take it take
advantage of the week c4 pawn now so he
plays d Capra's on c4 b captures on c4
and night to b6 as there is no longer a
knight and e2 to defend the c4 pawn and
now Queen b3 is a possibility here but
you run into Bishop to e6 now there's a
double attack on the c4 pawn and here
you have to sacrifice upon d5 captures
captures and after Knight captures
Knight to g5 now threatening to capture
the bishop on e6 and ruin black's pawn
structure Knight to f4 opening up a
discovered attack from the bishop to the
Queen now Knight captures the knife
captures and located e1 and white does
have compensation for the pawn in terms
of activity this night is very awkwardly
placed of what does also keep the bishop
pair and whites pieces are a bit more
active but this is not a part of
Carlson's preparation he doesn't go for
Queen to b3 rather he goes for c5 he
attacks this Knight and b6 we have
Knight to c4 and now Bishop to c1
protecting the bishop with Queen to b3
it doesn't really make sense you don't
want to lose the bishop pair and also
Queen b3 would run into Bishop to e6 so
yeah the Queen can never really stay on
b3 so after night the c-4 Bishop to c1
and now comes Knight to d5 and here
Carlsen goes for Queen to b3 Carlson's
first reaction was Queen to you one but
then he saw that after night the before
the threat of being night - C - he
doesn't really have all that much here
okay he does have this e for that was
his plan but after e4 Bishop to g4 the
Queen can no longer stay there you have
to move the Queen as night to c2 is
still a threat so after Queen d1 Bishop
captures and then the d4 pawn is a we
commercial capture screen captures white
losses upon and black like definitely
has a better game
you know it could be even winning it's
ok after Knight to d5 Queen to b3
Knights the a5 now attacking the Queen
Queen to a3 and now Alan repeats the
position Knight to c4 if if I don't
wanted to go for something more here he
could have played b6 and then you know
continued playing this game but this is
the first game of the match and you know
he does have the black pieces so after
Queen e3 and repeated Knight to c4 and
after some consideration of Queen to b3
was played on unrepeated Knight to a5
Queen to a3 was played and after Knight
to c4 only 16 moves were played in round
1 of the 2013 World Chess Championship
match here the players agreed to a draw
so you know it's definitely the case in
most world chess championship matches
that the first game will end in a draw
not another very eventful game unless
you check out Bobby Fischer vs Boris
Spassky our Fischer sacrifices all or
blunders a bishop for a pawn and you
know creates a very dramatic round 1 but
you know that's that's Fischer and also
who in his return match against Spassky
official also created a brilliant in
round 1 but that's Bobby Fischer so yeah
that was the first game of the 2013
World Chess Championship match between
Magus Clausen Viswanathan Anand we will
get some more dramatic games as the
match continues but like I said I'm very
very much looking forward to going
through the entire match game by game
and you know really increasing my
knowledge of this this event so yeah I I
do hope you enjoyed it the presentation
at the game not so much as it is a very
short game I would like to thank Ken
blink and Zachary hankins for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon which game 2 of the 2013
candidates tournament and a very special
announcement there exists a possibility
that I will do
an interview with a very special person
that person is the son of the legendary
Rasheeda Neji Medina but this is all
still you know hanging in the air so I
will keep you informed how that goes so
I thank you all and I will see you soon